okay let's go next to our caller from
the nine one six area code who's calling
today from nine one six
hey David this is Ronald calling from
Sacramento hey Ronald what's going on
hey yeah just two quick questions of the
show I just wanted to ask from 1969 to
1993
aside from four years of Jimmy Carter
from 77-81 it was all Republican do you
think there's any chance of the left
getting that same kind of run in today's
honestly no I mean the reason that I
would say no is that there are a bunch
of structural elements that favor the
Republican Party we've talked about the
fact that gerrymandering makes it so
that at the national level Democrats
need more than half of the votes to
secure half of the districts in an
electoral college presidential election
it's a little different but similar
logic applies the fact that
conservatives tend to live more in rural
areas and left-wingers in urban areas
also favors in the map Republicans voter
suppression and fewer people voting
favors Republicans Trump now has put two
people on the Supreme Court who are
going to be influencing the court for
decades including in election law
related areas which favors Republicans
so I see it as very unlikely that
Democrats will have the run that
Republicans had unless there is some
kind of drastic change or a backfire
effect to the Trump presidency that's
bigger than what we're seeing I don't
see it as very likely yeah I agree and I
thought I was just being a pessimist but
like I'm originally from LA and the
amount of like make America great again
hats I've seen in like areas like the
Inland Empire and you know like even the
like like Orange County right like every
time Trump writes off California I'm
like and we there are plenty of people
out here rooting for you they just you
happen to be white and from California
but yeah the reverse of the Texas thing
I mean California is a very blue state
and Texas is often considered a very red
state although less so recently but what
you've got to understand is there are
still millions of voters in California
who
Trump and if it weren't for those
coastal cities Trump could win and in
Texas there's also millions of voters
who do not like Republicans and they're
mostly congregated in cities even though
in raw numbers Democrats still have a
big lead in California and Republicans
in Texas these are not like immutable
forever things and immigration as from
with from other states I'm talking about
as well as demographic changes can
really change these things over like a
ten to fifteen year period yeah and and
I I appreciate you say I'm off tonight
because I'd like looked all around for
the answer to this question and you know
that's the first time I've heard like
something that's really coherent and
last like quick question I want to ask
you is yeah even though it's being
treated like like a bathroom fight in
high school I think the reparations
conversation is it's important just
because of the country's history but do
you think because the big thing I've
heard from a lot of people is the like
the the example of like America will
give Israel four billion in military
support every year and you know it only
took America three years and to
basically erect Israel after like three
years after Holocaust do you think
that's a good example for why black
Americans deserve reparations and why
like the number should be higher no I've
never heard that and it doesn't sound
like a good analogy it sounds like a
losing argument to me I've never heard
that before I'd have to think about it
more but my instinct is that sounds
weird I don't really get it
Josh oka we I appreciate your your
answers and thanks so much for picking
up all right I appreciate the phone call
great to hear from you um okay that is
all the time I have today sorry to
everybody I didn't get to hope everybody
has a good 4th of July holiday
we will take calls again livestreams
upcoming on youtube and lots of other
great stuff quick break very important
audience questions that I will be
answering after this very short break